hello everyone and welcome back to the
quarterfinals of the fide World Cup we
are in round two and we have a very nice
game between an idiot abasava and
Village Gujarati it's the first game
that finished with a decisive result and
you guys will really enjoy this one now
uh this is the first game we're covering
by uh Ninja tabasov and uh he uh well
he's just the Dark Horse as the title
suggests of defeated World Cup he uh
he's uh well a lot a lot lower rated
than most of the players who have gotten
this far as you can see he's over 100
rating points lower rated than with it
but he uh well he defeated some
incredible players to just reach this
position here he defeated Makoto he
defeated dolor and fresename he defeated
an engineer he defeated Peter swindler
and he defeated Sally Salim and now he
faces a very strong Grandmaster Gujarati
he comes from uh from Azerbaijan and
it's uh well just very good for him as
he's the Local Hero this world cup is
being played in the capital of
Azerbaijan in Baku and the Baku has
produced some incredible players over
the years like Kasparov like mamadir of
like a kopian like a job of so I mean
incredibly incredible names and some
very very strong Grand Masters uh so
that being said let's check it out it
features the opening some of you really
love and some of you really hate it is
of course the London system so let's
check it out we have Ponte D4 Knight to
F6 and Knight to F3 we have Pawn to D5
and Bishop to F4 the London system is on
the board and with it counters it with
Pawn to C5 we have Pawn to E3 Knight to
C6 and now Knight B to D2 so going for
the standard setup with the pawns and
dark squares E6 and now Pawn to C3 with
Bishop D7 by vidit and pawn to H3 Now
sort of a waiting move uh Bishop to D6
with it wants to counter the bishop on
F4 and now D captures on C5 forcing
video to waste the tempo Bishop captures
and now Bishop to D3 now developing the
light Square Bishop Bishop actor D6 and
now we have a trade Bishop captures
Queen captors and there is a game where
castles was played it was played in a
very nice game in the world the blitz
Championship 2016 where we defeated
Levon arunyan with this Castle's move
but here we have Queen to C2 and it is
now as of movie 11 that we have a
completely new game so I don't know if
you realize but in pretty much all of
the games that we are covering from the
video World Cup players deviate from
known fear uh territory as soon as
possible uh everyone is so so incredibly
well prepared and that it you know it's
just that much better if you can get out
of uh you know safe Waters of opening
Theory as soon as possible uh of course
uh yeah and not uh uh you know uh for
yourself but uh for for your opponent
you want your your knowledge of the
theory to be vast and you want your
opponents to be you know struggling so
here we have Knights the E5 now offering
a trade of knights and Knight captures
on E5 we have Queen captures and just
Castles by Ninja uh with Bishop to D7
and now Pawn to E4 this is a standard
move in pretty much all of the lines you
have to break through here to free up
the Queen Bishop battery D captures an
E4 we have Knight captures and now
avoiding further trade-off pieces with
Knight to D5 and also the Knight is very
well placed on uh on D5 you can't really
kick it away with C4 the night the B4
comes attacks the queen attacks the
bishop it's so it's a very nicely
centralized Rook fte1 aligning The Rook
nicely with the queen but just Bishop to
C6 there are no good discoveries for the
moment uh we have Rook 8 and D1 and now
we have Castle's Queen side we have
Bishop to F1 since the bishop is on C6
controlling this long diagonal the
bishop on F1 will be a valiant defender
of the white king we have King to B8 and
now Queen to D2 now if the Knight moves
you might even consider a queen capture
78 idea and giving up the queen for two
Rooks so the queen quickly goes back to
C7
uh and now we have Knight to C5 uh Pawn
to H6 and now we have Pawn to C4 the
movie said that we couldn't play now it
is actually the best move and for a very
very particular reason I'm pretty sure
you already feel what that reason is we
have Knights the E7 and now Queen to C3
putting pressure on the G7 pawn and you
might be thinking well okay I mean we
have castles on opposite sides of the
board is it really that bad if if we
give up the G7 Pawn then we put some
Rooks on on the G file and completely
crush the white king the problem is
let's say you play something like okay
you know you can play something like B6
then Knight A6 uh obviously uh Forks
European and queen but let's say you
play a waiting move King to A8 okay we
capture on G7 and it looks great let's
play Rook D to G8 put pressure on the G2
Pawn uh White doesn't care just Queen
captures on F7 and the the bishop here
is such a such a great defender there's
just nothing to worry about here even if
you try something like Bishop captures
on G2 Bishop captures and now Queen
captures and C5 uh still the bishop is
not just an excellent Defender here and
the bishop is also an excellent
excellent attacker so it would be
foolish to try something like this as
white would be completely winning here
so instead after Queen to C3 we have
Knights the F5 the pawn is now defended
and now comes the move I'm sure you guys
were thinking about as you are thinking
about it all the time and it wins pretty
much all the games you see and that of
course is spawn to B4 Now Pawn to B5 is
coming that will kick away the bishop
then Ponte A4 is coming and how is black
to stop the pawn storm as the pawn storm
and the King's side isn't really uh even
in its infancy so let's check it out
Rook captures on D1 okay for the moment
stop spawn to B5 we have Rook captures
and Rook to d8 now with the threat of
Rook counters on D1 but this allows
white root captures on the eighth queen
captures and now in Egypt plays Pawn to
B5 so what does this mean for our good
friend the light Square Bishop Bishop
back to E8 and now Pawn to A4 and now uh
what what do you play here the problem
is something like Queen to D4 okay you
would very much enjoy trading Queens
here because you're you know be behind
uh in in space uh but after Queen to A3
uh what do you play let's say you play
something like Knight to H4 looks very
nice even Knights the E4 is possible now
uh what do you play here uh okay the
Knight is saying but you can't really
capture it otherwise the queen is coming
to E7 to f8 uh there's not much you can
do here also the Knight can come to D6
put pressure on the bishop terrible
terrible position uh for black so
instead after A4 King to C8 was played
you've seen how weak the black king is
on V8 and now Knight to B3 uh so what is
the idea behind Knight to B3 well you
will tell me what the idea behind Knight
to B3 is because here we have F6 and
pawn to A5 and now we have Queen to D1
stopping the Bishop from moving and uh
also there is a trick in the position
but now white is completely winning so
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for Ninja while I give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the idea
behind this uh moving of the night and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is of course Queen to B4
which would not be possible if the phone
was not already on B4 and then on B5 now
Queen to B4 uh guards the B5 pawn and C5
is Unstoppable the real idea is of
course you want to play C5 but then you
blunder the game after Bishop captures
on B5 now there's no way to actually
defend this so uh Queen to B4 stops all
of that and now C5 is Unstoppable we
have Pawn to B6 a capture some B6 a
captures and now Pawn to C5 and now uh
with his chances of remaining in
defeated World Cup are simply gone so
here B captures and C5 was played uh the
problem is okay you could go back with
something like Queen 38 but then Queen
to A4 and that I mean you you can see
what's happening here Queen to C7 Queen
to A6 with check we have Queen to B7 and
now C captures on B6 and and all of
black soaps are now gone so after Pawn
to C5 we have B captures uh on C5 and
now Queen captures on C5 with check King
to B8 and now Queen to B6 with check we
have King to C8 and now Queen capture
Sun E6 uh with its entire position just
falls apart Bishop to D7 we have Queen
to C4 with check King to d8 and now Pawn
to B6 uh the the past B Pawn is just too
strong Queen's coming to D6 but now
Queen to G8 with check you have to go ah
King d7r block with the bishop but uh
none of it is really really good B7 is
coming so King the E7 was played and now
Pawn to B7 we have Bishop 38 and now
Bishop to B5 uh the bishoper spends the
entire game on F1 but now comes into the
game with deadly purpose the thread of
course is we just trade everything on E8
and then bring a Queen into the game so
here if you capture then just the B8
Queen there's no move you can play here
Queen D1 checking H2 there are no more
useful checks so in the game we did
tried a few more spite checks because
you have to play something you could
just resign here but I mean you also
could give your opponent a chance to
maybe play the worst movie of his career
and uh you know it's um it's okay to do
so Queen to D1 with checking to H2 we
enter D6 would check G3 and again no
more useful checks for video so he plays
Bishop to F7 and he allows another queen
to enter the game Pawn to B8 becomes a
queen and here again if it could resign
but he was a true gentleman and he
allowed the Checkmate to appear on the
board which you almost never see because
it's so hard to allow this but with it
that's the kind of player of it is
Bishop capture sanju8 was played and now
ninja delivers Queen to E8 this is
Checkmate and this is the position that
eliminates the video from defeated World
Cup 2023 and the ninja abasov is now in
the semi-finals of defeated World Cup
and he is waiting for his next opponent
who will be well the winner of the match
Magnus Carlsen vs guker so he will face
either of them and we're gonna check out
what happens in the other games of the
match they are still all being played
while I'm recording this so I don't want
to spoil uh all or all that much uh but
yeah incredible play by Ninja at uh you
know uh he he he might become the next
big player from from backwards or by
John uh you know maybe becomes a legend
himself it's a it's a far too early to
tell as he is playing a tournament of
his life uh but you never know he might
just continue this uh uh Power Play you
know completely indefinitely uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
very nicely done by episode very
heartbreaking for vivid but what are you
gonna do it's I mean you you you come
all this far into defeated World Cup and
your opponent plays the London system I
mean it's it's like that no one takes it
seriously but then you know someone
plays a place plays it against you in
this uh you know uh high-stakes game
that can base is basically a ticket to
the candidates tournament and then you
just lose though it's uh I mean you have
to know how to play against the London
you know uh if you guys want you can
also check out my tutorial on the London
system uh I will also put a link to that
in the description below so you know be
ready for it uh so I once again really
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank Celine universe
and David Kimura for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the video
World Cup until it finishes so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day